combien de poules peuvent vivre dans un
poulailler en ville dans un poulailler
d'une superficie de 10 mètres carrés le
maximum de poule est de 4 mais cela peut
varier d'une ville à l'autre car chaque
municipalité à ses propres règlements
par exemple à saint-jérôme vaudreuil
dorion ou saint-hyacinthe les citadins
peuvent avoir jusqu'à cinq pôles à la
maison et comme les pôles aime la
compagnie dans l'arrondissement rosemont
la petite patrie à montréal on exige un
minimum de deux poules par poulailler
à québec le poulailler doit être
installé à 3 mètres d'une porte d'une
fenêtre dans la cour arrière seulement
ailleurs comme à montréal le poulailler
est toléré sur les terrains latéraux
s'il est installé à au moins un mètre et
demi de l'alim de l'eau mais toutes les
villes défendre l'installation des
poulaillers en façade ou sur le balcon
de la maison et pour assurer la
tranquillité du voisinage les poules
doivent passer la nuit au poulailler et
la garde du coq ce chanteur matinale est
prohibé dans presque toutes les villes
et municipalités du québec